e libere
il fatto che non la continui una
pugnalata nello sterno e non ha
continuato ad altri ragazzi e benvenuti
questo video sono fa vj oggi sto
vestendo il paracetamolo la maglia del
paracetamolo no è la maglia di shine
quella che indossava gli intanto su
instagram allora ragazzuoli ultimamente
dexter che è quello della serie tv che
squadre come un altro per fare abbiamo
fatto abbiamo fatto una cosa strana
praticamente di essere un giorno mi ha
chiamato mi fa renzo sai volevo fare una
cosa volevo provare a finger mite per un
giorno che tipo di farina hai preso
quella non era farina del raccoglierà
un'altra però l'idea [ __ ] quindi ho
detto va bene in che cosa consiste
questa cosa mi ha detto lui consiste nel
caricare delle mie foto su instagram sul
suo profilo fingendosi me cioè come se
avessi preso il possesso del suo canale
sia instagram che canale youtube perché
poi ha caricato un video miu miu video
sul suo canale come si caricasse un
video di buono soldi l'ex lipidi paio di
tecnici sul mio canale senza dire niente
a nessuno e abbiamo condito questa cosa
anche con delle storici organizzato mi
dicevo che mandami delle storie dove
dici ciao ragazzi sto uscendo che le
metto nella mia storia mi ha fatto un
cambio di identità c'è lui è stato me
per un giorno
non so quanto sia stato bello per lui
visto che è un sacco di gente gli ha
scritto ma fa vigente ha creato il
canale che tipo di farina musica hanno
chiesto anche gli altri alcuni è stato
un esperimento figo perché alcune
persone e questo è molto interessante
alcune persone non capivano tipo quando
guardavano il mio video sul suo canale
pensavano di essere sul mio canale
questo fa capire quanto la gente in
realtà click i suoi video senza guardare
chi li sta pubblicando
semplicemente perché li volevo guardare
ma andiamo con ordine e vediamo come
sono andate le cose
la giornata iniziata sul profilo di
dexter lo so apprendo dal computer
quindi si vede un po strano tanto perché
questa foto ma l'edizione 2013 la prima
volta che sono stato in america ma
voglio tornarci qual è il posto più
bello dove siete stati metto cuore a chi
ha lo stesso mio
ps oggi live perché quel giorno ad un
live comunque è luca è però non mi far
passare un po come una [ __ ] cene sensi
non scrivo così
almeno normale screen normale e niente i
commenti sono stati parte questa volta
fatto 120.000 like ok
leggendo un paio di reazioni del web
andiamo a leggere cose come ma tutti
quelli che scrivono mai fa vj ma che
problemi avete prove del genere sei
cambiato non sei più fa vj di una volta
vecchia gut è così quindi si è capito un
po più questa cosa era è appunto un
troll se non fosse andata un po troppo
avanti la sera gli ho mandato questa
foto ottimo camuffamento per uscire
stasera e la gente qui ha iniziato a non
capire quindi nelle mie fan page
raga non ci sto capendo le mie fan page
dentro ma perché a parte che non è una
fantastica cara
non so cosa sia successo insomma cosa
del genere sono stati i commenti più poi
poi un sacco di gente mi ha scritto va
che dexter da facendo delle cose va bene
finché finché non è uscito il video di
giornata
ecco è qui andiamo nel nel trash ho
dovuto bloccare il mio network può
bloccarlo perché se uno li carica mio
video automaticamente gli arriva viene
monetizzato da me e gli arriva uno
strike sul canale più di dovuto bloccare
mio network per dirgli proprio guarda
che guarda che dexter sta per caricare
un mio video vini tranquilli ed extra
caricato sul suo canale
prima di lui era un mio vecchio video e
la gente anche qui è diventata scemo ma
è un bug di youtube
anche perché ormai siamo in argomento
bug quindi diamo è colpa di youtube di
cosa non funziona è colpa di dexter ma
ti sei fatto di favi cocaina stamattina
anche questo potrebbe essere vero sono
confuso ma che canale questo grande suri
bel video e vabbè comunque il commento
che mi ha
scorso un attivo di più è stato tipo
quello che vi dicevo prima solo a metà
video mi sono accorto che stavo
guardando video di famiglie sui canali
dexter e questa è curiosissimo perché la
gente in realtà quelli che sono iscritti
a youtube a più canali non guardano a
chi pubblica un video cliccando sul
video e basta
molte volte strano c'è non avrei mai
detta sta roba qua e questa è appunto
l'unica cosa di questo se vogliamo
chiamarlo esperimento sociale che è
l'unica cosa che mi ha scosso un
attimino perché vuol dire che allora
chissenefrega
t come chiami il canale puoi anche
chiamarti pino il formaggino oppure toni
petronio al posto di famiglia in tv è
tanto la gente se metti la copertina che
la mia faccia lo apre pensa che sono io
wow
pare comunque tutta stava per della alla
fine per arrivare a quello che alla fine
è stato il beh penso il la spiegazione
finale anche da parte di dexter che
volevo appunto vedere che non ha ancora
visto
avg mi ha chiamato i social va bene
grazie per avermi dato la colpa a terra
tutti ragazzi venuti allora forse non ci
stiamo capendo look non devi farmi
passare per forza con un mono neuroni co
maledizione cioè non c'è bisogno però
vabbè facciamo finta nella sconfitta di
milano e secondo non sono parigi e in
maglieri lo sono stato per tutta la
giornata su tutti i miei social come
vede visto dai instagram a youtube dalle
stories tratto è curiosissima una cosa
che non c'entra una sega avvio adesso
non c'entra una sega
la canzone che sta usando dexter in
sottofondo e disconnected dei peg
corners che è stata una delle mie
non lo so se l'hai fatto apposta ad
essere mettere questa che è stata la mia
colonna sonora agli inizi di youtube che
poi ho dovuto togliere perché mela
copyright avano cosa sei tu un dio in
terra che non ti copyright a non le
calcola se hai minacciato youtube di
morte non mi mette dei copri come hai
fatto a mettere sta canzone di
sottofondo sei pazzo no lui capire non
ce l'ha dexter
lui è un sicario anni avanti ed è
successo un casino
gente che vediamo sul parquet gente che
pensa fosse hackerato gente che pensava
che fossi ciccio game
in realtà non è stata tutta una beh
allora non per entrare nel dettaglio per
carità di dio ci mancherebbe altro
ciccio io lo adoro però non sembra
proprio ciccio gamer
c'è un po di differenza tra me e ciccio
gamer bapista e non è non per altro
insomma sono un attimino pezzo di carta
io devi essere bocelli per non per dire
una cosa del genere però va be blood
organizzata con lorenzo per poi fare
questo video dove leggerò tutte le
reazioni che avete avuto suoi ragazzi
l'altro la tattica di dexter allora
parte mente nelle canzoni completate e
non lo copyright hanno quindi fantastico
ma lui del web
questa persona del web ha capito tutto
ciò che si è fatto le views e con il
primo video che era mio quindi non ha
fatto niente perché il video lavoro
montato io l'avevo fatto io quindi
chiuse a caso con un mio video e il
giorno dopo video sul sul video del
giorno prima e altre views a caso quindi
quest'uomo ha capito tutto del web
questo è il nuovo salvatore aranzulla il
mi riferisco a dexter
chapeau zio ma sembri fa vj avevano nè
fini nè ragazzi perché c'è destra non è
che fa solo mette sulla foto ma c'è
stata anche una storia bella ragazza è
uscita la nuova foto battetelo ipad 2
ragazzi sta maglia cielo da dada tipo
tre giorni è successo tre giorni faccio
ancora la maglia del paracetamolo perchè
perchè pensate che non mi la viper che
non è così
mamma se stai guardando questo video la
maglia lo lavata tutti i giorni e l'ho
rimessa giorno e attenzione genio del
giorno ma se tu uefa vj
non lo so non lo so raga non è possibile
io ci credo non è possibile ripetono la
chirurgia estetica
fate le cose incredibili e fatti di esse
potrà diventare o me o greta menti e
forse non so se ti è andata meglio o
peggio però insomma il chirurgo si è
dato da fare a prescindere
va bene i capelli sono la parte più
difficile comunque pali fammi sapere
hanno scritto ciao luca a questo punto
si o no per un set però tipo stormi mi
ha scritto tipo questo cioè stormi che
mi ha scritto credevo dexter fosse
diverso su un whatsapp alcuni mi avevano
scritto effettivamente europa tipo
dexter ti sta copiando il look
io io ve lo giuro non io non capisco
alle volte rimango allibito da alcune
rob e cioè non è possibile non ci
somigliamo per niente quindi dopo questo
video ha all'interno di sé una morale
ovvero e non vi scambiate per farvi j
ma chi era cos'è sta roba
la bella showgirl dove ti trovi questi
video cosa era va bene ragazzi hobo sono
sciocca comunque ottimo esperimento
sociale io no ci vogliono palle per fare
una roba del genere lo riconosco quindi
figo
un giorno mi fiderò più dipanano quello
lo faccio comunque ragazzi prima di
concludere io ne approfitto perché io e
dexter comunque ci conosciamo da hbo
penso secoli migliaia di anni fa lui
fece questa cosa c'è ma io penso che lui
abbia più video miei nel suo canale che
io nel mio canale com'è possibile
madonna siamo orribili siamo orribili
siamo orribili e veramente kringe questa
cosa e khrin gissi ma io non doveva
aprire questo video maledetto non lo
aprirò mai più però
e sono abbastanza
entrambi siamo due strateghi del
successo su youtube
se però ragazzi che vi sia piaciuto come
al solito se video piaciuto al momento è
un mi piace anche vari secondi dove
iniziare so se questi discrete via fa vj
tanto siamo entrambi dj noi ci vediamo
al prossimo video su cui in teoria su
questo canale poi vabbè tanto ormai si
capisce vi niente bella ragazzi
[Musica]